SEE YOU MONDAY.
GREG GUTFELD TAKES IT ALL FROM
HERE.
HAVE A GOOD WEEKEND.
>> ALL OF MY FANTASIES --
FANTASIES INVOLVE HANDCUFFS.
>> ARE YOU THE ONE PUTTING ON
THE HANDCUFFS?
>> TO BE CLEAR, I'M ALWAYS
PUTTING ON THE HANDCUFFS.
>> Greg: NOT THIS TIME.
IT'S TIME ONCE AGAIN FOR...
>> HOW IRREDEEMABLY STUPID IS
THIS STUPID MEDIA.
IT'S IRREDEEMABLY STUPID.
WHY ARE YOU ASKING, GREG?
>> Greg: LIGHTEN UP,
VOICE-OVER GUY.
HOW IRREDEEMABLY STUPID IS THE
MEDIA?
THIS THEORY D MOBLEY STUPID.
>> YOU GOT LUCKY TONIGHT.
WE ARE BACK WITH ATTORNEY
MICHAEL AVENATTI.
>> TO ME YOU ARE LIKE THE
HOLY SPIRIT.
YOU ARE ALL PLACES AT ALL TIMES.
>> HE IS OUT THERE SAVING THE
COUNTRY.
>> I THINK YOU ARE DOING A HELL
OF A JOB.
>> LOOKING AT 2020, ONE OF THE
REASONS I'M TAKING YOU SERIOUSLY
IS BECAUSE OF YOUR PRESENCE ON
CABLE NEWS.
>> A ROCK STAR.
>> Greg: THE TITLE OF THE NEXT
CHAPTER IS IN "YOU ARE ALL
STUPID IDIOTS."
BEHOLD.
SPEAK WITH A LAWYER WHO
REPRESENTED PORN STAR
STORMY DANIELS AND LEGAL BATTLES
WITH FORMER PRESIDENT TRUMP
SENTENCE OR TWO AND A HALF YEARN
PRISON.
A JURY CONVICTED AVENATTI OF
TRYING TO EXTORT $20 MILLION
FROM NIKE.
HE FACES TWO MORE TRIALS.
>> Greg: THERE GOES THE
MEDIA'S WORST PRESIDENTIAL
HOPEFUL SINCE HILLARY.
A FEDERAL JUDGE SENTENCED TO 30
MONTHS, A MONTH FOR EVERY SELFIE
HE TOOK WITH A CNN ANCHOR.
NOT QUITE THREE YEARS, ROUGHLY
THE AMOUNT OF TIME LEFT IN KAT'S
MARRIAGE.
OR KILMEADE'S HAIRLINE.
AND THIS BIRD TRYING TO EXTORT
MILLIONS FROM NIKE, HE IT HEADED
TO A FEDERAL FACILITY TO OREGON.
BETWEEN THE OPTIONS, I WOULD
STILL TAKE OREGON.
LIKE MANY CREEPY EXHIBITIONISTS,
KILMEADE ROSE TO FAME ON THE
BACK OF STORMY DANIELS.
YES, BUT HE REALLY GOT A BOOST
FROM THE DRILLING MEDIA WHO SAW
THEM AS THE TINIER HAIRLESS
VERSION OF TRUMP LEICA HOPPED UP
HAMSTER.
IT WENT ACCORDING TO PLAN.
FOR ABOUT 10 MINUTES.
NOW HE IS DONE, RUINED, FIRST
EMBRACED AND THEN SPIT OUT BY
THE MEDIA WHO ADORED HIM BUT NO
LONGER WANT HIM AROUND TO REMIND
EVERYONE ELSE OF THEIR OWN
IDIOCY.
NOW YOU WON'T SEE THEM ON CABLE
UNLESS IT'S AN EPISODE OF
"LOCKUP: EXTENDED STAY."
YES, HE USED THE MEDIA.
THEY USED HIM TOO.
YOU CAN BET THAT ALTHOUGH CNN
FAN BOYS AREN'T ANSWERING HIS
CALLS ANYMORE EXCEPT MAYBE BRIAN
STELTER WHO IS LONELIER NOW THAT
HE WAS AN LAUNCH IN THE
HIGH SCHOOL CAFETERIA.
IS IT WRONG TO TAKE A VICTORY
LAP?
IT'S MY FAVORITE FORM OF CARDIO.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT THE MEDIA
WHO THINKS YOU ARE STUPID AND
THAT THEY ARE ALWAYS RIGHT ON
EVERYTHING.
WHEN THEY TURN OUT TO BE WRONG,
THEY MEMORY HOLE IT FASTER THAN
JOE BIDEN BEING ASKED WHAT HE
HAD FOR BREAKFAST.
ALMOST ALL THE MEDIA'S HANDIWORK
IS A HATE CRIME HOAX AGAINST
YOU.
THEY SPEND THEIR CAREERS MAKING
YOU INTO THE BAD GUY WHILE
ELEVATING CREEPS LIKE AVENATTI
WHO BUY THEIR OWN NARCISSISM
THEY ELEVATED HIM SO THEY COULD
LOOK COOL.
AVENATTI HAD MORE PROBLEMS THAN
A "FOX & FRIENDS" COOKING
SEGMENT.
AND HE MAKES KAT LOOK MORE
WHOLESOME THAN A MULTIGRAIN
BREAKFAST CEREAL.
THEY TOOK PICTURES WITH THEM,
PARTIED WITH HIM.
NOW THEY LOOK LIKE TOOLS BECAUSE
THEY ARE TOOLS.
HIS TOOLS.
I WONDER IF BRIAN STELTER WILL
ADMIT HIS HUMILIATION ON
RELIABLE SOURCES BECAUSE IF HE
DOESN'T, HOW CAN HE BE
CONSIDERED RELIABLE.
JUST ADMIT YOU SCREWED UP AND BE
DONE WITH IT.
YOU WON'T ANYMORE THAN RACHEL,
"THE VIEW" OR CUOMO.
BEFORE THE COURT, AVENATTI CRIED
LIKE A NEWBORN BABY CITING
TWITTER AS EVIL THAT FUELED HIS
THIRST FOR FAME.
HE IS RIGHT.
HE GOT TO TREND ON TWITTER MORE
THAN A KARDASHIAN BUTT PICK.
DO YOU THINK ANY BLUE CHECKS ON
TWITTER OR EXECUTIVES IN CNN
BOARDROOMS CARE ABOUT HIM?
THEY ARE RUNNING FROM HIM LIKE
HE'S A CICADA WITH CORONA.
WHAT ABOUT ANA NAVARRO WHO
COMPARED THEM TO THE
HOLY SPIRIT?
NOW IT IS THE FATHER, THE SUN,
AND "PLEASE LOSE MY NUMBER."
WILL SHE VISIT HIS CHRISTLIKE
FIGURE IN JAIL OR GO THE JUDAS
ROUTE AND PRETEND HE NO LONGER
EXISTS LIKE SHE DOES WITH HER
PRINCIPLES.
FOX GOT HIS NUMBER STRAIGHT
AWAY.
REMEMBER THIS MOMENT?
>> YOU HAVE PROFITED FROM
STORMING -- STORMY DANIELS.
SHE IS WORKING AND STRIP CLUBS.
YOU ARE EXPLOITING HER AND YOU
KNOW IT.
WHY AREN'T YOU PAYING HER SOME
OF WHAT YOU'RE MAKING?
ANSWER MY QUESTION.
WHY ARE YOU RICH AND YOUR CLIENT
IS WORKING IN CITY STRIP CLUBS.
YOU ARE ON EVERY CABLE SHOW.
YOU ARE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
NOW.
I KNOW YOU HAVEN'T PAID YOUR
TAXES.
LIKE SO MANY LAWYERS YOU ARE
TAKING ADVANTAGE OF HER.
YOU POSE AS A FEMINIST HERO
BECAUSE YOU ARE SHAMELESS AND
THE OTHER CHANNELS LET YOU GET
AWAY WITH IT BUT YOU ARE AN
EXPLOITER OF A WOMAN AND YOU
SHOULD BE ASHAMED OF IT.
>> Greg: WOW.
I THINK THAT WAS LONGER FOR
AVENATTI IN THE PRISON TERM.
"REVIEW" SAW IT DIFFERENTLY.
>> MY TAKE AWAY WAS THAT
AVENATTI CAME OUT ON TOP BECAUSE
THAT WAS TUCKER CARLSON SHOW.
THAT CHYRON ON THE BOTTOM IS
TALKING TO HIM -- CALLING HIM A
CREEPY POINT LAWYER.
THE WOMAN HAS A BOOK OUT AND
SHE'S MAKING MONEY.
>> BLAMING HIM?
>> WHAT IS THE PHRASE, THE POT
CALLING THE KETTLE BLACK.
>> MY FATHER USED TO SAY PEOPLE
WHO LIVE IN GLASS HOUSES SHOULD
DRESS IN THE CELLAR.
>> Greg: MY FATHER USED TO SAY
THAT JOY BEHAR MAKES NO [BLEEP]
SENSE.
MEANWHILE.
MEANWHILE AFTER EMBRACING
AVENATTI FOR SO LONG, HOW IS CNN
COVERING AVENATTI NOW?
>> LOOK, I NEVER LIKED THE GUY.
TOTAL FRAUD.
>> I NEVER STOOD OUTSIDE HIS
WINDOW PLAYING "SEXUAL HEALING."
>> I DIDN'T ASK HIM OR.
>> Greg: AVENATTI SHOWS US HOW
THE MEDIA WORKS AND HOW IT
DOESN'T.
IT WAS RAVING AND HATES THREATS
TO RATINGS, ITS INFLUENCE OR
POWER.
THEY THOUGHT AVENATTI WAS THE
PERFECT ALLY BUT IT IS LIKE WHEN
KISS TOOK OFF THEIR MAKEUP.
IT ALL BACKFIRED.
WHAT DO THEY DO NOW?
WE KNOW THE MEDIA, THEY WILL
PRETEND LIKE NOTHING HAPPENED.
THE STORY WILL VANISH LIKE
JOY REID'S HOMOPHOBIC BLOG POSTS
BECAUSE IN THE END, THEY ARE ALL
RATS, JUST LIKE AVENATTI JUST
WITH MORE PLACES TO HIDE.
WELCOME!
TONIGHT'S GUESTS.
HE DID STAND UP FOR 10 YEARS
UNTIL SOMEONE REALIZED
YOU'RE PERFECT FOR A JOB
WITHOUT LAUGHTER.
"FOX AND FRIENDS" CO-HOST
BRIAN KILMEADE.
AS A VEGAN, SHE WON'T HURT
HURT ANIMALS,
BUT PEOPLE?
THAT'S ANOTHER STORY.
FOX BUSINESS NETWORK ANCHOR
DAGEN McDOWELL.
HIS AUDIENCES SHOUT REQUESTS
LIKE "PLEASE STOP TALKING."
COMEDIAN JOE MACHI.
AND SHE'S A TEN.
BUT ENOUGH ABOUT
HER BLOOD ALCOHOL CONTENT.
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR KAT TIMPF.
BRIAN, YOU HAVE BEEN HERE 20
YEARS.
YOU MADE A LOT OF MISTAKES.
A LOT.
WE HAVE SEEN.
ALMOST LIKE EVERY WEEK.
IT IS A PARADE OF ERRORS.
BUT YOU AT LEAST ADMIT YOUR
ERRORS.
SHOULD THE MEDIA THAT FAWNED
OVER THE SKY APOLOGIZE?
>> Brian: CAN I LOOK AT THE
STAT SHEET?
A LOT OF ERRORS?
I AGREE WITH YOU ABOUT THE
COOKING SEGMENTS.
A COUPLE THINGS.
BY THE WAY, THIS CROWD OF 4,000.
THEY ARE FANTASTIC.
MOST IMPORTANT, THEY LIKE YOU.
THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN A LOT.
SPEAK TO EVERY PERSON THAT CAME
AND GOT FREE EDIBLE.
>> Brian: DEFINITELY NOT A
"FOX & FRIENDS" COOKING SEGMENT
HAND OUT.
ENOUGH NIKE.
A COMPANY THAT PREFERS TO BE
FROM CHINA.
EXTORTED BY A LAWYER WITH NO
ETHICS, NOT A BIG STORY.
WHAT HE DID TO HIS OTHER
CLIENTS, THE PARAPLEGIC.
HE TOOK MONEY.
THEY HAD NO RECOURSE TO GET THE
MONEY BACK.
DIDN'T KNOW HOW MUCH THEY WERE
AWARDED.
STORMY DANIELS.
WHETHER YOU THINK SHE'S A VICTIM
OR NOT, HE TOOK OVER $300,000
FROM THIS WOMAN.
TUCKER WAS RIGHT ON THE MONEY.
74 APPEARANCES ON CNN IN TEN
WEEKS.
TEN WEEKS.
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE.
THERE SHOULD BE A HUGE APOLOGY
FROM ANDERSON COOPER AND
COMPANY.
DO YOU THINK IT WILL COME?
>> Greg: IT WON'T.
THAT'S WHY I ASKED YOU THAT
QUESTION.
>> Brian: YOU DIDN'T ASK ME
THAT QUESTION.
>> Greg: I THINK I DID.
LET'S ROLL IT BACK.
>> Brian: I THINK YOU JUST
TALKED ABOUT MY RECORD.
>> Greg: DAGEN I THINK IT WAS
ME WHO SAID IT SAYS SOMETHING
THAT STORMY DANIELS, A
PORN STAR, OR WORST DECISION WAS
HIRING AVENATTI.
I THINK YOU SAID THAT.
>> Kat: I MAY HAVE SAID THAT.
I CAN'T REMEMBER EVERYTHING I
SAY.
>> Greg: EITHER I SAID IT OR
YOU SET IT BUT EITHER WAY, I
SAID IT.
DAGEN, YOU ARE FROM THE SOUTH.
FILL IN THE INSULTS AND GO TO
YOUR ANSWER.
>> Dagen: EVERYONE I GREW UP
WITH COULD HAVE SEEN THIS GUY
FROM SATELLITE IMAGERY.
WE CAN SPOT A PHONY IMMEDIATELY.
THESE KIND OF NEWS HUCKSTERS ON
CNN, THEY NEED MICHAEL AVENATTI
OR A MICHAEL AVENATTI.
THEY NEED SOMEONE MORE REPUGNANT
THAN THEY ARE, MORE ODIOUS THAN
THEY ARE SO THEY APPEAR KIND OF,
SORT OF NORMAL.
THIS IS THEIR VERSION OF
BALANCE.
IT'S LIKE IF I'M SITTING NEXT TO
THIS FLEA STACK, NOT YOU, JOE.
I KIND OF LOOK LIKE A HUMAN.
CNN'S NEW SLOGAN.
BETTER GET A BUCKET.
>> Greg: IS INTERESTING, THEIR
LEGAL EXPERTISE GOES FROM
AVENATTI TO JEFFREY TOOBIN.
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION.
WHO WOULD YOU RATHER BE, JEFFREY
TOOBIN OR MICHAEL AVENATTI?
I DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE THAT'S NOT A GOOD
QUESTION.
IN 2024, HE WILL BE OUT SO YOU
COULD BECOME -- HE COULD JOIN
THE CNN LINEUP.
FOR THE ELECTIONS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, JOE?
>> Joe: IT IS SOMETHING THAT I
LEARNED EARLY ON.
THEY SAY THE ENEMY OF YOUR ENEMY
IS YOUR FRIEND BY THE ENEMY OF
YOUR ENEMY CAN ALSO BE YOUR
ENEMY.
I HAVE A LOT OF ENEMIES.
BUT YEAH, WHERE HE WENT WRONG
WAS TRYING TO EXTORT 19.
THAT'S LIKE TRYING TO EXTORT JOY
BEHAR FOR HAVING A JOKE THAT
DOESN'T WORK.
THEY DON'T CARE ABOUT THEIR
REPUTATION AT ALL.
>> Kat: IT'S WEIRD.
YOU GET A COUPLE COMPLEMENT FROM
BRIAN STELTER AND YOU ARE LIKE,
YOU KNOW WHAT, I THINK I CAN
EXTORT NIKE.
[LAUGHTER]
I DON'T GET HOW YOU GET FROM A
TO B, SOME SORT OF NURSES IN.
I'VE BEEN ON CABLE NEWS A LOT A
LOT OF VINYL BECOME THAT GREAT.
>> Greg: AND YOU HAVEN'T
EXTORTED ANYBODY.
EXCEPT THAT OLD FELLOW DOWNTOWN.
THE PICTURES.
THEY DO HAVE LEGAL LIBRARIES
THAT ARE AVAILABLE TO PRISONERS,
SO HE COULD STILL BECOME A
LAWYER.
>> Brian: HE IS LOOKING AT
MORE CHARGES.
IT'S GOING TO GET WORSE FOR HIM,
BELIEVE IT OR NOT.
HOW UNBELIEVABLE IS IT THAT WE
HAVEN'T POINTED OUT THE BIGGER
PICTURE.
HE WAS HIRED SO TO SPEAK TO TAKE
ON TRUMP.
HE WAS GOING TO TAKE DOWN TRUMP.
IT WASN'T SO MUCH MAKING THEM
LOOK BAD OR GOOD.
WE CAN'T TOUCH TRUMP.
GOT A GUY THAT CAN AND WHAT HE
GOT IS MICHAEL COHEN ON HOUSE
ARREST.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
ANOTHER CNN CONTRIBUTOR.
WE CAN LET PEOPLE FORGET ABOUT
AVENATTI.
THE MEDIA WANTS US TO FORGET
ABOUT IT BECAUSE IT'S A REMINDER
OF THEIR INCOMPETENCE.
>> Joe: IT DIDN'T WORK FOR MY
MC HAMMER PANTS AND JUNIOR
HIGH SCHOOL AND IT WON'T FOR
CNN.
>> Dagen: I UNDERSTAND LOW
EXPECTATIONS, LOW SELF-ESTEEM.
YOU WANT TO READ DOWN, NOT UP TO
MAKE YOURSELF FEEL BETTER.
I'VE GOT TO SAY I'VE NEVER
HOOKED UP WITH SOMEBODY THAT
DISGUSTING.
>> Greg: THERE IS STILL TIME.
>> Dagen: I HAVE BEEN THERE.
>> Kat: I DON'T KNOW IF I CAN
SAY THE SAME.
>> Greg: I WAS GOING TO ASK
BEFORE I GO, NOW THAT HE'S GOING
TO PRISON, IS HE MORE ATTRACTIVE
TO YOU.
>> Kat: BEFORE MY HUSBAND,
YE